there can i can i show you one of the
cringiest things online
i mean no and i mean this mike we've
been doing this show
we've been doing this this show for
three years right
so this specific show for three years
but what you and i have been doing
have been doing radio in some form or
another for at least 12 13 years i mean
for a long time we've been doing this
so we have seen a
lot of cringy things in our life i mean
you would agree we've seen some of the
worst
that the internet has to offer
i want to introduce you to andrew curtis
okay
i'm just going to play it i'm going to
give you no comment i'm just going to
play the tick tock guy and he's also on
youtube
on youtube he has like 480 000
subscribers if i see a man and a tick
tock logo i'm already cringing so
hear that ryan long so [ __ ] a [ __ ]
all right here you go oh
hi there my name's charmander
and i recently learned a new trick
uh well i can turn myself into a wolf
can i show you
okay bear with me here or should i say
wolf with me here
okay one second
look at it he's a wolf now look at it
he's a he's a wolf
i look at it everyone look at it
i can't do this
um this that's a
[Music]
perfectly normal behavior i think trip
please don't do that though
trick i don't know why
he talks like uh lindsay from kid
stuff's face expressions
he's by the way i don't know if you
noticed what you swear to god no
this [ __ ] chad no way dude i swear to
christ
get the [ __ ] out of town i wouldn't
think it when you look at him right i
thought this guy was awash in a sea of
puss
someone throw my life right yeah
seriously i was trying to save this kid
not really someone throw him a life raft
you got to be [ __ ] me
yeah i don't know i i'd like to jury's
still out on that one
there is a would you say cringiest guy
really think about it because maybe i'm
wrong but i still don't know if he's the
most
cringe i've seen more embarrassing
things on the internet but he's up there
all right well that's that's fair i mean
i might i thought that would to me at
least
it's up there it's a top five contender
i think in history right right
uh i need to see more of this guy though
we need we need somebody to get on tick
tock and get us all this guy's hot
videos
i have seen a couple other ones i've
seen his youtube stuff his youtube
videos are
robbie turns into a bat and catch
[Laughter]
can i give you one more one more tick
tock video that might be up there
sure this is a different guy god
tick-tock is so
this is a different guy but uh
let's see this is
glim herc
now there are people that love this guy
i mean the comments are like this is the
next jim
carrey really yes
so he's riddled with these and he's got
an x that killed themselves
i'm almost sure of the first part i
don't know about the second part
this isn't milo here you go
that's it he's the next jim carrey
because he can lip-sync
he's the next jim carrey you know i
don't even like jim carrey but
let's let's defend jim carrey for a
second here sure
he literally had like a face made of
rubber in the 90s
to his credit it was more than just
over-enunciating words and a lip-sync
jim carrey
could do [ __ ] with his face and body
that was
bizarre and and and unnatural
you know what i mean like and again i'm
not a big his [ __ ] i go back and watch
jim carrey's stuff and it's very cringy
yeah none of it holds up but you have to
[ __ ] he did what was basically
the original la comedy which was i'm not
going out to la to be a [ __ ]
brilliant
you know t-shirt uh black t-shirt
wearing bill cigarette smoking guy i'm
gonna be
and i want to make it a lot of money you
get into those
big movies by being a rubber man that's
you go there and it's like america's got
talent and you go
you know my dad was uh you know he was a
real uh card
[Laughter]
but you use that as a chance to be like
i'm a rubber person
so i'm not really into that kind of
comedy but this that's an insult to jim
carrey jim carrey was
uh at least fulfilled the role
if you had a sketch comedy show you'd
hire him in a heartbeat right
yeah yeah i mean you would i guess but i
don't know i also think it's the timing
it's it's the
that stuff made sense you look back at
it now it's cringe but that stuff made
sense when jim carrey was doing it right
like
back then i don't think it's the same
now like it's it's like
watch ace ventura now and tell me it's
just funny oh no yeah it's movies and
stuff
that's all i mean though just for a
sketch show it's good only it i just
mean when you have a guy like that that
you go
all right well we have jim and jim can
do literally anything so that's just it
just comes in handy for all right well
we're writing
you can write jim to basically do
anything because he's made of rubber
it's like phil hartman phil hartman was
great because he just was so
that guy could melt into any mold it was
like all right we just
we have phil hartman if we need a black
jazz singer we'll just use
phil hartman